a follow-up to a story from last week
this is pretty interesting
um
jessie lee peterson
caused a car accident across the street
from his
christian young men's counseling center
when being um asked questions by someone
on the street and dr rashad richie
covered it he also covered my coverage
of jessie lee peterson i'll give you the
back story jesse lee peterson is this
very outspoken
pro-trump black conservative pastor
and he's very homophobic he has spent
his career talking about sin and
being gay is bad and all these different
things and now numerous individuals have
come forward saying they were in gay
relationships with jessie lee peterson
that they were
um accosted for lack of a better term by
jessie lee peterson and i told my story
last week of how when i was in a studio
jesse lee peterson was very handsy with
me i didn't make much of it and it
wasn't sexual harassment or whatever
well dr rashad ritchie covered this he
mentions my coverage of jessie lee
peterson and he has the video of this
car accident that was caused by jessie
lee looking like he's going to step out
in front of fast-moving traffic to try
to get away from these questions check
this out follow up not only is
anti-lgbtq
pastor jesse lee peterson gay
he's a
predator he may have even hit on david
pakman
and he ran away
and caused an accident when someone
confronted him
here's the video
hey jesse peterson
martin francis here
how are you
so this is the post office right across
the street from his uh studio which i
visited
so i'm the first man in your whole
career
i am the first man in your whole career
that you have run from
like the chicken song that you play
you are running from me
so now jessie lee is approaching a
crosswalk sometimes traffic gets going
pretty fast here and he looks like he's
just going to step right into it car
slams on its brakes car behind it slams
into that car
you're running from your from your uh
what you've been doing for 31 years
there it is
god and jesse lee doesn't even react to
the car wreck he causes
jesse's so upset that he uh tried to
cross the street before he should have
and caused these cars to stop and bash
and back and that's pretty serious
damage
so
[Music]
tell me about you sleeping with your
brother's wife so quite a scene there
folks uh jessie lee peterson
quite literally causing an accident out
on the road as he uh stepped in now i i
want to mention a couple of different
things about this story
number one
after i said last week
that
jesse was just very touchy with me
um uh
i'm so you know just that was my
personal experience i got a bunch of
emails from people saying
david don't you think he realized that
you're that you're gay and that you're
open to a relationship with him or
whatever okay i'm not gay and also he
wasn't
publicly acknowledging that he was gay
at the time either so that's like a
really strange thing to send me number
two some people wrote to me saying david
why are you outing jessie lee peterson
jesse lee peterson has not acknowledged
that he is gay so you're doing something
wrong no i i i have not outed jessica
peterson i'm re reporting on stories
written about him that's what i'm doing
so the people writing to me and saying
even talking about it is wrong as if i'm
the one asserting that he's gay i have
no personal knowledge of that we're
talking about widely reported
uh claims
and number three would i go back on his
show sure yeah absolutely i would love
to go on his show and talk about this
why did he why did he feel as though
he couldn't just be who he was
uh that's terribly sad and i would want
to revisit my conversation with him
where he said he was celibate
um there's a lot i would want to talk to
him about so absolutely i would appear
on his show again
as many of you know i take my snacks
very seriously i avoid excess sugar and
junk food and so when i want something
sweet
i go to our sponsor monk pack monk pack
makes my favorite granola bars and nut
and seed bars if you're doing keto it
works just one gram of sugar or less
only two to three net carbs under 150
calories the flavors are delicious sea
salt dark chocolate that's my favorite
you've got your coconut cocoa chip
you've got your caramel sea salt the
texture the flavors this is a beautiful
granola bar and then you've got monk
packs nut and seed bars which are more
crunchy if you're craving something like
a crunchy chocolate candy bar monk pack
is the perfect thing to grab instead
same taste same experience none of the
carbs and sugars and calories
get 20 percent off your first order at
monkpack.com using the code pacman at
checkout the link is down below